uh aryans also said that that brown is
starting from ground zero in the offense
that
their their time together in pittsburgh
is irrelevant that pittsburgh changed
things after aryans was fired right that
what aryans used back then isn't the
same and he's got to learn other than
the route tree which is largely
universal he's he's got to learn
everything from scratch
someone suggested last night that maybe
he doesn't scott zolac is pushing the
idea on 98.5 the sports hub in boston
that
that brady and and i've heard bits and
pieces of this got together with antonio
brown super bowl week and zolac said
that that brady talked to antonio brown
and told him he wasn't going to be back
with the patriots most likely but stay
ready he would get him signed wherever
brady ended up signing i can't help but
wonder
whether or not maybe antonio brown has
had a playbook for a while right you
know i mean or or you know
i mean
maybe he was at one of those uh sessions
in the summer that we just assumed was
all buccaneers players i mean unless
someone's at ground level taking photos
of everyone there how do you know
antonio brown's not one of the guys you
know seriously so i i i think that
brady's smart enough to know that if you
want to get the most out of this guy
right out of the gates
there's some preparation work you need
to do and i would it stun anyone if we
found out that brady and brown found a
way to get connected before this even
happened no it would not it would not
stun me i mean i wouldn't be shocked if
maybe two months ago he you know yeah
like you said
a little small playbook or a print out
packet of hey here's formations and all
the basic routes whatever that whatever
that is
also too you know yeah learning the
offense all those things but i would say
this out of all the positions in
football to where
you might be able to hit the ground
running the quickest
wide receiver would be one of them
because again
even if you don't know
as long as you're talented nobody's
gonna give a damn and brady will babysit
him through the huddle and as they break
the huddle hey go over there to ten yard
out hey oh no no over here post corner
okay yeah okay all right hey hey if it's
cover two run the go route if it's
single safety i want you to run the curl
route it'll be that easy he'll just take
care of them that way so i you know i
don't look at it that way to be it's
gonna be this huge huge adjustment
because i think they will make sure he's
ready and brady's going to make sure
he's ready and all that and hey i
understand them signing it signing him i
still don't buy bruce and like tom had
nothing to do with that he can't sell me
that sorry there slugger but
i do think that they probably realized
man godwin and evans are hurt and when
they're both hurt all of a sudden we
gotta depend on some guys that maybe we
don't wanna really trust yet and they're
your super bowl team and they don't
wanna have to deal with that if it gets
later in the year and some big games
you make a great point about the
receiver position though and i think the
farther you are from the ball right the
less intricate your assignments your
your
work isn't as intertwined with someone
else exactly you're out there
you and the quarterback right you may
have an option route you need to run you
may need to know what you know if it's
inside or outside leverage where do i go
where i do where's the ball going to be
but that all comes down to your
relationship with the quarterback it
does he's already got he's already got
the relationship with the quarterback
right brady saw enough from him in a
limited time together with new england
last year to make brady convinced that
wherever he goes this guy needs to be on
the team period and it finally happened
and you know what it happened right
about the time
that it could have happened because he
was suspended eight games anyway yeah so
it's not like they could have signed him
any earlier what's the point of signing
him earlier there's no point he can't do
anything
wait until
the last minute use that carrot to keep
him on the straight and narrow that's
right which which he has managed to do
and and then you bring him in and you
see what happens and you know i'm
thinking that
that the bruce arians deflection that
tom brady had nothing to do with this
and
you know we thought it's just let's not
make it look like bruce arians has
surrendered the keys to the car to tom
brady even though we already knew he had
maybe he's throwing dirt on the idea
that there was something going on
between tom brady and antonio brown and
maybe there was some stuff being
discussed when brown wasn't a member of
the team and maybe there have been
playbooks and other i'm just i'm
speculating based on the fact
based on the fact
that it seems like the buccaneers have
said the hell with whatever they could
catch us doing when gronk had the
playbook in the off season as you know
with that oh no i was just joking oh i'm
just joking
you weren't supposed to have it oh i'm
just joking sorry yeah no okay you're
sure there yeah
let me tell you i've heard that a lot
lately i'm just joking apparently that
is the get out of jail free card for
anything you say that that someone tries
to
to repeat to you you just say i was just
joking yeah
yeah it worked when i was seven
i i didn't think it was something adults
used as well but apparently i was just
joking is a very effective tool so uh
anytime i let me just say this now just
as a blanket
moving forward
anything objectionable that i may say
any bad take i may have any bad
prognostication i may proffer
i was just joking yeah is it does it
work does it work are more serious
matters in the world that that phrase
gets used for and people seem to be okay
with it this is just sports who cares
um
what do you think crystal ball
saints bucks sunday night football
nbc
over under on number of plays antonio
brown is on the field for okay i'll go
i'm gonna say
set that line
somewhere like i think a fair line would
be to set it at like 15 20 plays maybe
somewhere in there i mean somewhere in
that i would say it's less than 20 but
maybe more than 15. that would be my
guess about how much he gets on the
field and they'll keep it simple for him
early and he'll be on the outside and
run very basic routes and things like
that but we'll see i mean hey the bucks
you know i think we're both in the same
agreement if you ask me who the best
team in the nfc is right now i'd take
the bucks
and i think you're the same way right or
are you still on the ceo okay no i agree
with you i'm on the bus
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports